his family kind of complicit in the
abuse they knew what was going on and
they just turned a blind eye or was it
secret to them
they were aware they didn't condone it
um there was one incident where his his
mum did say that
she's the that brought him into the
world she'll be there to take him take
him out obviously but that was because
it was right in front of her
um
majority of the time I would spend time
at his mum's
um In fairness and she was amazing and
she was she's been in a great amazing
grandmother
um to the girls so
they they know their identity they know
where they come from and they know his
entire family the only person that
they've not had contact with is him